good morning good morning good morning
how come you're sleeping with me right
now
papa's in california with sonic yes oh
you're just staying everything all
together
ow
okay
let's keep going so like take it
he's rolling
like tyka said papa is in california he
left
last night
and um
uh last night was kind of not last night
but yesterday was kind of interesting
for us because it finally
happened and i feel like every kid
goes through this
taika sophie
what sofika
let me see your eyes
so let's look at tyka's eyes
look at this
one darker circle
i mean so i saw that last let me see
your eyes please
i saw this last uh yesterday when i
picked them up too close when i picked
them up from school
and when i looked this eye was pink go
back
thank you
this eye was pink and that eye was white
and if you look it's still kind of like
that
okay
he passed out
taika has
pink eye
yellow
and yellow eye um it's highly contagious
i've had it as a kid
i remember it having it one time it was
so severe
like there's so much of that like green
okay if you've never heard of pink guy
lucky you but
basically there's like bacteria in your
eye
and then um you start getting like this
yellowish almost greenish like discharge
like like mucus in it and there's a lot
of it
i had it to the point where i went to
bed i woke up and my eye was shut
because there's so much of that mucus
it's so gross coming out so when i saw
his i'm like whoa because i picked him
up from school like what happened did
someone hit you
because if you don't know any better it
looks like someone beat him up
this was a little bit more swollen
yesterday than it is today
um but yeah like it was just red i'm
like what happened because i don't know
but it's really itchy and i'm like oh
because that's another side effect of it
or symptoms
whoa
come
on
got him
so yeah when i looked i pulled his
eyelid down i looked inside and i
started seeing some of that because i'm
like nope we are going to get some
medication so immediately i got
this
this is the first time i ever had to
treat it on someone else because my mom
treated it on me
and i never had it since then
bozo um yeah so did this it's good for
kids
um i think anything over two is good
and you put about two drops and i think
it's homeopathic um use as often as
needed so it's redness burning watery
discharge discharge sensation of what is
this woody grittiness okay i don't know
if he knows what grittiness is
um yes i shook it
put two drops in i put about like eight
drops last night
and then it does say here that it will
get worse before it gets better
so i'm like okay thank you says symptoms
wait no no no no no
directions
remove neck no i was reading it
somewhere
where can you be
baby
um
i don't know but yeah basically it just
told me like
it might get wor it will get worse
before it gets better that's just the
nature of homeopathic
um
yeah anyway but this is what i'm
throwing on him sorry i was like reading
it the entire time
[Music]
so i figured out a way to put it uh in
my cell first because putting eye drops
in myself
um was always difficult
uh just because i can't even my contacts
i never put it in this way so there's
some people that just do blip they just
look at it and they put it on i can't do
that until this day i can't so what i do
is i look up
and i put it the bottom of my eye
and then i just let it find its way
onto my eye
um i use that same philosophy when
putting
or giving oh distributing distributing
eye drops
um
i'll pull it down for taika and i have
him look at the ceiling look they see
like
yep just like that
[Music]
you're the best
um
look at the ceiling
um
look at the ceiling
oh
i should make you do that when you're
taking a picture look at the ceiling
yep pretty good voila
he's gone
please
okay yeah he'll look at the ceiling and
then i'll
put a drop or two
and then
because this is this is where the show
is i'll just talk while you watch him
yeah and then i'll just put two drops
and we'll call it a day
dairy day
you ready for your drops the washes mom
i'm gonna follow the blanket okay
oh dude
i thought
i thought you were gonna brace for it
you just let yourself don't do that
anymore okay did you hurt your knee no
no are you okay
yes no yeah yes
no don't because it's not there's no
cushion
yeah but you missed the cushion
completely
oh my god
okay we're done
he's putting on a show for you guys i
hope you know
what'd you say monkey
i vlogged you is what you wanted me to
do
you got you got a mustache on your
forehead
they don't know what you're talking
about
so i was putting drops in his head i
mean in his head monkey i was putting
drops in his on his eyes no not on
stomach no on your eyes and i had him
lay on a pillow here so i was laying
down
crisscross applesauce style and then
show them show them how i did it and
then you lay down or show it
okay
and then he was like this and he was
looking at me we were staring at each
other for so long that you said what's
on my forehead
um
that's a mushroom yeah he kept looking
at me and my eyebrows because you know
how her face is upside down so my
eyebrows look like i had a mustache and
i was like yeah it looks like you have
um a mouth on your forehead and we were
cracking that pong yeah look look i'm
gonna put it like this
i hope your eye feels better i hope your
eyes are lit
let me see does it look better i don't
know it's always the worst when kids are
sick or
um they're just not feeling well
with the cold or pink eye or anything
else to make egg headache whatever um
it just makes me so sad because i wish i
could i wish i could like take their
place you know because i'm like oh i
don't want you to suffer you're so
perfect you're so brand new
um
but i guess i'm done vlogging
no okay brush your teeth
[Music]
did you do 10 times
i don't know you count can you do it
again
no you do look
go 10 times
go 100.000
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so i understand i'm using an electric
toothbrush and i wasn't using it the
correct way i know i'm supposed to turn
it on and just let the brush do its work
i understand that but when it comes to
brushing my teeth alongside taika i like
to uh be an example if you will of how
brushing teeth should be because as you
guys know
yeah let's brush his teeth
he's still learning how to do it so
i understand that another thing fun fact
did you guys know
he did let me see his teeth i remember
everyone had a problem with the movie
and sonic's
teeth smell his breath
wow smells good it smells like soft
flour sunflower what does sunflower
smell like
[Music]
um fun fact do you guys know why there's
a color
on the toothbrush like that that blue do
you know why it's blue like this
because i have a little toothpaste no
oh what do you mean i think you might be
onto something here why is it blue like
that
like mine has that too kind of
see mine has a little instead of the
blue it has
white because because
it gets more blue yeah well kind of
you're kind of close you want to know
why because if you put on the white
there's more blue no
do i tell you what do you want to know
oh i thought toothpaste the reason why
it's that blue like that let me show you
yep that's the amount of toothpaste that
you need on the brush that's the that
isn't that such a little amount yeah but
but not the white no that's that's the
amount you should be putting on your
toothbrush it's already measured for you
what
but
come on let's go eat breakfast okay
but yeah fun fact
i don't know how many of you guys knew
that but yeah this is the amount of
toothbrush that you should be using that
little of an amount so the ones you know
what i think messed me up because when i
learned that i was like wait then why
did the commercial show it go completely
across the entire like all of the
bristles you playing with me
oh no this doesn't happen
you're stuck oh yeah you look real stuck
dude
so today's a friday tyka's supposed to
be at school i have a bunch of meetings
today i got a train today
but because of his eye
yep pink and red eye
um i don't think he's going to school i
don't i don't think it's good for me to
send him to school one because i can't
monitor him and prevent him from
scratching his eye too it's highly
contagious like it's really really
contagious so i don't want him i don't
know sharing toys with another kid
now that's what i'm talking about
and possibly getting more kids sick or
not sick but like
having them get pink eye so
it's going to be kind of challenging for
me today because today we're also
driving to california
because tomorrow is my friend anna's uh
daughter's
one year birthday
oh pretty cool thank you sonic
um it's her one-year birthday party and
um yeah i would have missed that for the
world so we're leaving today gotta get
away from this guy because this guy
loves the camera and he loves impressing
you guys i hope you know that
um so i thought he's doing all these
like theatrical
things
theatrics i don't know why i said that
just woke up sorry it's been a morning
it's not even 7am yet and there's
just so much that's happened already
parents
i know you feel me thank you
taika
yeah
yeah
oh my god
those are my favorite ones on youtube
do you want them no thanks they're so
cool thank you
why are you smelling it
downstairs now i just changed to train
and i must say
this is such a freaking cool outfit i
never know what i'm gonna wear
until i look at one piece this is like a
vintage
49ers jersey to be like anyone no
um and i'm like whoa
what a cool fit
yeah
getting this dude making whoa making
this dude some breakfast he's gonna have
some oatmeal in water
it doesn't look very good trust me it's
good if you have a bland pellet like
myself actually
it's actually really got natural light
there oh my god that didn't do anything
better
but yeah oatmeal and water a little bit
of honey
a dash a sprinkle of cinnamon
and taco really loves it so i have him
eat that in the morning because it's um
very filling
it's good
for him he's not eating super sugary
things early in the morning i'm not a
big fan of that um
i'm out of breath i was just posing
that's all i did
i was posing and now i'm out of breath
so i'm gonna wait for that to cool down
a little bit
as i'm waiting for that to cool down a
bit i'm going to take my pre-workout
because i'm about to train
of course you know i have to plug
my
my business here um barbell brigade
pre-workout honestly is my favorite
workout if it wasn't my favorite
i
wouldn't say that for sure
but like you gotta trust me you gotta
trust me when i say that this is
actually my favorite like i'm almost
done with it like you see that um i
drink it every training session
because it allows me to focus it
actually it's thermogenic so it like
starts warming me up from the inside out
um allows me to focus gives me the
energy oh my god
with the kid man
coffee just ain't gonna cut it for some
people that's all they need coffee green
tea
um that's all they need as their
pre-workout some people don't even need
pre-workout i know before tiger i would
never take pre-workout unless i was
competing in a powerlifting meet
then i would take it only
at the end of the meet
or like the last part of the meet which
is when you deadlift and that's when i
really needed to bring it so then that's
when i would take it but since
my bundle of joy has arrived
my sleep
is almost non-existent so pre-workout
is a must if you want to try it which i
highly recommend you try it if you
haven't tried it yet um go to barbell
brigade.com check out our pre-workout we
also have other supplements like we have
greens we have immunity support um and
protein
creatine is out of stock at the moment
but we are getting it uh in april
so we have all your supplement needs oh
you also have multivitamins and that's
literally all we take we don't
do fluff we don't um we don't produce
anything we're not gonna use and other
than those things
we don't need anything else
honestly so we're not going to sell you
anything else because
then we're just
giving you stuff we would never buy and
that's just not cool you know what i
mean so
yeah
i just closed the lid when i haven't
even taken it yet so take it i'm gonna
get ready gonna get in the zone
pour his oatmeal on the plate we're
gonna go to the gym he's gonna watch
ipad cause he never gets to watch ipad
are you excited to watch your ipad
yep yeah in the garage
[Music]
yeah
i'm gonna train we're gonna do dead lips
today
by we i mean me
and uh
[Music]
oh that's why i said we good job
okay so our garage tends to be a little
bit chilly especially if you're just
sitting down when you're training your
body gets warmed up so um you don't even
really feel how cold it is just because
you're so damn hot again because you're
training um
so for someone that's just new now and
like the way taika is gonna be sitting
down i hook him up with a little heater
i have a little chair for him and then
our we have a box here
and then he's just gonna grab
watch his ipad when mama goes and does
some work or at least pretends to do
some work i don't know
woke up today with a migraine
i shouldn't say migraine headache a
really bad headache
so we'll see
how i do wish me luck thank you very
much
okay so i just finished training it's
been about two hours now since taika
woke up and i put those eye drops taika
can we get an eye update i think it
looks better come here duty
oh let me just show you too a picture of
the before
come here monkey
oh thank you very much
here's a picture of his before
when i picked him up from school
yesterday
so this is his oh this is it before
you see his how his eyes swollen
and it's teary yes you put that in the
trash
he's got tears in there
now monkey come here
stand right there
this is taika after
wow
i don't know why it got purple like that
but at least it's not puffy anymore
and it's not swollen it's white oh yeah
and they're white
good job we did it
okay what are we gonna do now
not yet
why you're gonna play i'm gonna work
you're gonna play i'm gonna work oh
thank you oh thank you
we're at that stage
okay so now it's two o'clock we haven't
had lunch yet i've been
in meetings
yes now we're going to grandma's house i
had to film a couple things before the
podcast it's just
it's just a couple things you know but
we are packed
ready to go
tyka has this comfy outfit on
because it's gonna be a long car ride
and i'd like to always bring my mom some
sort of fruit or something so i'm
bringing her a bunch of oranges i got
some avocados some ciabatta bread and
anything that's perishable that i feel
like
huh should i leave it over the weekend
i don't think i should bring all this
stuff
huh
bread yeah
we're gonna eat right now but yeah
basically we're ready to go
let's go ready
a hot dog
okay we'll go get a hot dog
okay
okay look at how beautiful all these
clouds are god darn it cars look at that
isn't it gorgeous monkey monkey
i know because i think it's so beautiful
no i can't come here and look you silly
goose
oh it's so beautiful look at all of this
wait wait wait no yeah baby the cars are
stopping i got to pay attention i'm not
even looking at what i'm really
recording but i know i'm pointing at
some oh look at mine
look at that little car
a floatie oh that's a
pecunian say what you want about traffic
but i'm not going to lie it always looks
really beautiful when i see all lights
like that
hey pickle chill out
you chill out pickle head
where are you at right there there you
are
hey you little monkey strudel butt butt
hello
hey
you little chicken wings
hey i'm talking to him on the rear view
here
hey what's your name
okay okay like look at that like how
pretty does that look
it's like it's like christmas lights
on the freeway
hey
cut it out you little troll
look at that look at that
hey
stop it
ah i didn't get to record i was talking
the whole time and i didn't record any
of it okay what i was saying was look at
all these clouds
and then
look at this orange sky as the sun sets
how absolutely gorgeous is this
it reminds me of the intro scene of lion
king yes monkey
we are going to grandma's house
oh bless
okay
so i made it to la and for everyone that
has been asking and every day
she's right there
she misses you guys too hundreds of
millions
we're gonna have movie night so i'm
gonna spend some quality time with my
family um and i will see you guys
tomorrow